all right you filthy little two-timer
okay let i
let me explain myself a little bit yeah
i'm not gonna make any excuses all right
i'm not gonna make this is not an excuse
i get it
i need therapy i'm a bad logical liar
whatever i read all the [ __ ] comments
dude i was just like
oh god
i've i just i've never felt so ashamed
that's i think the hardest i've laughed
in a long ass time
wait so you have some news on that do
you want to go first or do you want me
to tell you what people said at the
shows first
uh
let me go first okay okay yeah i didn't
know if well no actually maybe i think i
think because
it is a good like i you know something
yeah yeah no it will it will so
um there's like people would be like
damn this is the funniest moment in tmg
history cody you need help
so i'm reading the comment like
oh
yeah it's gonna be so funny now whenever
you tell stories people are gonna like
turn it up a little bit and just lift
her eyebrow like
that's funny but i'm gonna take it with
a grain of salt yeah if you misremember
details they're never gonna let you
[ __ ] give it down
sure bro yeah sure cody do we know this
happened i worked at that coffee shop
you mentioned and you're wearing a green
shirt and you said you're wearing a
black one
i will say though i did appreciate some
of the comments some people said you
know this is this is uh and i use this a
lot as a crutch i agree but it's a
canadian thing maybe
oh yeah i don't want to derail the
conversation yeah
to me it would be more awkward for me to
be like no i didn't do that well you
know what i'm making excuses again yeah
people said you know it's like this is a
it's just the niceness
i'll go with that yeah so all canadians
are liars
no we're nice okay we're nice
we want to keep the conversation flowing
okay what's a better moment no dude
actually you're wrong i didn't invest or
my friend and business partner
jared goff good to see you and what's a
better moment that is a better moment
and then when you find out they lied to
you that's a worse moment
and i'll read you go first and then i'll
read it i had a conversation with jared
after the fact
i kind of was like well i'll never talk
to that guy again yeah
you know that bridge is burned so
smithereens
so every show i did
this weekend
every q a
so that was that a that was a bit right
every show really yo so like how did
like
when cody lied again like that that was
a bit right like you guys wrote that
so someone said that you guys wrote that
and i was like no
yes you can't keep getting away with it
you can't keep getting away with it
we did here the whole thing was fake we
got you
did we oh
we don't know
we don't know
i wish it was fake
dude
and then so when i would say no it
wasn't a bit there would be a decent
like handful of people in the crowd that
didn't believe me they would go no no i
was definitely a bit there's no way he
did it twice it was too perfect that's
why it's not a bit if you re-watch it
all the everyone's reactions and the
cadence of the way like people it like
it has to be real yeah well that's why i
said i told everyone i'm like go back
and watch i don't even laugh for the
first 15 seconds because i'm immediately
angry that we didn't record it because i
looked at this camera
zack had cut these cameras yeah um
so i didn't realize all three were
rolling over here so i was that's why
i'm like do we do did we get it did we
get it that was only when everyone like
confirmed yeah we got it then you know i
let it loose but yeah yeah no there's no
way that that could have been scripted i
was just dying laughing
now that was real
i swear
[Laughter]
oh man it's gonna be really funny when
you do ad reads now i love this product
i use it all the time
i love
what was that [ __ ] picture frame
oh wow oh let's just [ __ ] let's just
burn this bridge do it i don't know the
skylight picture frame skylight picture
dude
nothing better than sending being able
to send your mom dick
straight to her
over email yeah over email to her
skylight picture frame
howard we're just playing it's a sick
product yeah this thing in valentine's
day might be coming up so there there
might be an ad read for that
six out of seven cody cos rated the best
skylight frame that you could ever have
do i no okay all right here here you're
the seventh dentist dude
you're the seventh dentist what does
that mean that doesn't rate the
toothpaste you know it's like six out of
six yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're the one that lies and says no i
don't [ __ ]
but you do [ __ ] with it so i like i said
last or like i said just now i just kind
of thought oh well i'll never talk to
that guy again as soon as he sees this
clip he'll be like this dude's a piece
of [ __ ]
what did i even do come like coming on
that show in in the first place uh and
then he dms me and he said sorry hold on
just a lot of celebrities in here yeah
yeah
so many um
yeah yeah jesus [ __ ] christ
guys remember that cody has a lot of
celebrities in his dms his words not
mine i'll read this and this will kind
of explain
my thought process right again no
excuses but this is
the reason i think why it happened
uh he said thought we were only telling
the truth now lol and i said bro i don't
know what what the [ __ ] is wrong with me
and uh he said i guess i got bad info
from the friday beers guy and i said no
i texted max that's the founder of
friday beers a couple months ago and
said hey
i'm not going to invest in this round
but count me in in the next round and
that to me in the moment made us
business partners
and he said gotcha and i was like i i
was going to invest i had the forms and
everything then i bought an engagement
ring and something else at the same time
so all of a sudden i had zero cash and
so i had to go back to the guy and be
like listen i'm i can't do it right now
i have no cash but next round i'm
definitely in yeah
and and then i said anyway sorry for
lying once again and he said we almost
made it through too and i said i didn't
know i was a pathological liar but you
learn something new every day
and uh he's like might have to connect
you to a lie detector
uh when that comes and i said we'll
invest in a polygraph for the next time
you're on the pod yeah and he said
perfect yeah
well we'll make sure we get a very
unique polygraph in here yeah
okay all right it's gonna kick in the
balls every time you
and it's gonna have like a meter so it
can measure like if you're fibbing a
little bit so you can feel the
the foot will start to like it's going
to be a foot on an arm that kicks you in
the balls and if you start fibbing it's
going to start pulling back
it's like a kind of like pinocchio you'd
be like what what what
i'm not lying
did you invest in friday beers
well i i was going to and i was okay
okay no no i didn't
yeah yeah
you [ __ ] little pinocchio
[Laughter]
yeah so sorry again i apologize to
everyone yeah i am seeking therapy
you're gonna watch man you're gonna dude
you're gonna get
you're gonna get in your first therapy
session and the therapist is gonna be
like oh you're the
[ __ ] are that you're the guy who lied to
jerry got me yeah
she's like okay
uh payment up front
and how do you feel about this whole
jared goff thing i just feel really bad
do you do you
sure yeah okay
okay buddy this is telling a really
traumatic experience and then you're
like it made me feel horrible yeah i bet
i bet you felt really horrible
what nothing
yeah speaking of social yeah that was
another one of the comments
bro this is so funny literally laughing
so hard funniest moment ever in tmg
history cody's a sociopath yeah what a
[ __ ]
you're literally ted bundy
jesus [ __ ] christ yeah